c'est dans un immeuble c'est une vieille
dame qui rentre dans l'ascenseur est
comme ça fait très laid très très
vieille dame que la gueule oui et non
parce que l'offre était plus l'ascenseur
s'ouvre allait tâcher une très belle
blonde qui rentre comme ça tu vas sans
pause instagram lui et qui se retourne
vers la vie' lui dit dior 100 euros la
bouteille et la porte se referme ça
descend d'un étage et une autre fille
blonde très belle encore plus belle qui
hante encore plus parfumé qui regardent
la vieille dame griffée chanel 300 euros
la bouteille et ça arrive au
rez-de-chaussée la porte s'ouvre et la
petite vieille elle sort et elle largue
une énorme caisse et est retourné à fait
flasher de l'aide chez lidl 4 centimes
[Musique]
tous ces mecs carnot à part avec un
perroquet sur l'épaule encore il arrive
et je venais ici s'il vous plaît et le
perroquet un côté et moi ça serait bon
qu'à toi tu fermes ta gueule
ben oui s'il vous plaît et moi un conte
cas tu arrêtes tu fermes ta gueule à
whisky s'il vous plaît bon si tu as
continué ce scotch sur le mur tu as
compris ok un whisky s'il vous plaît
monsieur il prend le perroquet il se
balade sur le mur il reste collée sur le
mur
hélas le perron qui se retrouve à côté
d'un crucifix avec jésus dessus il dit
au site a quand même des congrès
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maurice qui croise la vie dans le
sentier qui dit dix mois en maurice j'ai
appris par et ton magasin il a brûlé
l'eau tu fiches la semaine prochaine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut blangy proximité d'un asile yayi
dans nos bons non monsieur nom n'a pas
de nom non la partie s'emballe mais oui
ou non non je disais d'hier ont fait un
topo
ils reviennent ça et tu es cobain est
acquise la voyant rien venir nous
n'avons rien fait non non à battre à
tokyo on à bagdad au bureau puis c'est
quoi la vj quinzaine a fait sa demande
pour faire ta tombola qui envoie et
trouver trentaine de tortues pour toute
la nuit il fit riche beau et plus tard
de hbo vient il ya bientôt nous pourrons
et oui oui maintenant du monde aimé
ramond
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça se passe dans les années peut-être
vous voilà c'est l'examen de fin d'année
donc là le docteur qui armé de trois
fous qui demande aux premiers fous il
dit
trois fois quatre fois mercredi
il appelle le deuxième lilly 3 x 4
dia 1485 merlus pas possible il apprend
le troisième 3.4 direct du 10 12 10 mais
comment tu as fait dit j'ai divisé
mercredi par 1400
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]